the fallout from that calamitous mother
testimony continued to reverberate today
and the questions keep mounting how was
a man who was obviously so detached from
key aspects of the case ever allowed to
run the investigation why didn't they
end the investigation when they realized
there was no collusion or conspiracy to
throw the election
how could Muller not have known anything
about fusion GPS and why wasn't the FISA
Court fully informed about the origins
of the dossier how did Trump hating
partisans managed to become key players
on Muller's team
why do elites always seem to get away
with the abuse of power when
conservatives like Trump are dragged
through the mud for something he didn't
even do well as to the last question the
elites in both parties let's face it
have a lot to answer for and it's up to
us to hold them accountable so this kind
of thing doesn't happen to ever again to
any president or frankly to any American
citizen so that no one is subjected to
defamation or saddled with massive legal
bills or has his or her entire life's
work and in this case his entire
presidency put in jeopardy
the fact is the so-called elites have
been failing us for decades and Trump
remember called them all out in 2016 I
don't think they ever forgave him elites
have been wrong about major history
altering issues
remember former Fed chair Alan Greenspan
they even called him the maestro well he
presided over the housing bubble and
along with Bill Clinton he thought it
was just peachy to allow China into the
World Trade Organization permanent
normal trade relations with China will
have profound implications with a free
world's trading system and the long term
growth potential of the American economy
and remember folks from the Bush years
like Paul Wolfowitz he was the architect
of the Iraq war well he also got Trump
wrong - is this the reason why you're
leaning Clinton over Trump because of
Trump's isolationist views look I'm
leaning against both of them I find it
incredibly disappointing when the
country needs to come together that we
have two major party candidates who
enjoy so little confidence from the
American people
that's funny confidence of the American
people according to a Pew Research poll
by 2008 only 38% of the country thought
the decision to invade Iraq was the
right decision well that of course
helped elect Barack Obama and as for
Obama he pledged to bringing a new team
of pros the elite of the elites who
would show everyone how governance is
really done well instead he brought us
anemic growth the Iran deal and an
Obamacare website that didn't even work
did you try signing on the site yourself
I have created an account on the site I
have not tried signing up because I have
did you find a challenging was I know
what did you think of it well I I think
there certainly are some challenges that
could be smoother it could be easier to
access and that's really what we're
working on nobody says the site is
working the way we want it to wait a
second I thought they were gonna be the
smartest people ever and yesterday of
course we were reminded that the
American taxpayers spent 34 million
dollars for an investigation that could
have been easily handled by the regular
line prosecutors at the Justice
Department an investigation led by a man
who was clearly past his prime so past
his prime that he didn't bother doing a
conflict check on the team he assembled
Andrew Weissman attended Hillary
Clinton's election night party did you
know that before after he came on to the
team don't know when I found that out
are you aware that Miss Jean Erie
represented Hillary Clinton in
litigation regarding personal emails
original originating from Clinton's time
as Secretary of State
yes did you know that before she came on
the toe again a first-year associate at
pretty
Jenny Law Firm knows that the mere
appearance of bias or conflict is often
enough to require recusal from any case
in this situation with the stakes so
high this was of paramount importance
and by the way each lawyer on Muller's
team had an affirmative legal obligation
under the ethics rules to consider their
own anti-trump bias and decline the
offers to work on the russian collusion
investigation given their past
connections to the democrats my friends
republicans must hold them accountable
and get real answers as to why this team
was allowed to operate outside the code
of Professional Responsibility that all
of us attorneys are subject to or heaven
forbid this travesty could happen again
and that's the angle